now he's saying the type of women and
beauty terms i would love to go after
are victoria's secret models
so yes it any
even knows you know this is ridiculous
and stupid for him to have these goals
and expectations um
i will say this i i i ran across this
guy
once and i think i mentioned this in a
video at one point it might even be
be pinned in my um i'm gonna throw this
back on i'm cold it's freaking winter
here
but um you know i ran into this guy that
used to own
three uh eight-story buildings um
you know when i was working in the
credit and collection world and he was a
little dude he used to keep his exotic
cars in the underground parking lot
he looked like danny devito you know the
guy was like
five foot five bad you know like holding
on to scraps balding
uh wasn't good looking at all probably
like a three out of ten but every time i
saw him down in the underground you know
picking up one of his cars
he was always with a young hot like
supermodel looking check
okay was he packing 10 inches i don't
know probably not based on his height
but he had bank that's the thing guys
like
there's you can this comes down to like
a
like a world view like shift because
there's you can find
plenty of examples in the world of dudes
who are
short bowling ugly tiny dicks
pulling supermodels like
you can find them if you want to find
them these are endless examples of this
in the real world this is not
fantasyland and we're not even talking
like celebrities we're just talking guys
who've done well in life
you know guys who've put in the effort
to level up
you know and obviously this guy's like
okay
at 23 you're very unlikely to be able to
pull a supermodel
okay because who are supermodels dating
supermodels are dating like really
top-tier dudes with with like status and
money et cetera okay cool
well that then you know where your goal
is at least so you've
you've identified where you want to be
that's a good first step
the second step is removing this
limiting belief and this frame of
reference on the world that you
currently have which is
not helping you in any way shape or form
this idea that you're limiting your
genetics that you have
no way to change this at all
complete lie um
let's take a look at some stats here
because i kind of dug these up uh
countries with the largest erect penis
length around the world
this is ten one two this looks like the
top ten so ecuador
which is in latin america apparently if
you're from ecuador your average length
is just under 7 inches 6.93
all the way down to some of the african
countries netherlands is up at the top
there's a lot of tall guys in the
netherlands
you know men and women are dutch men and
women are very tall in fact so
there is a correlation between height um
and then the smallest
erect penis lengths um down to 3.95 so
this guy's saying he's 4.7 so
moved move to cambodia would be a good a
good recommendation because you're
actually
bigger than most guys in cambodia
because the average length is 3.9
correct uh burma taiwan philippines sri
lanka hong kong bangladesh
thailand vietnam and malaysia which goes
to 4.52 so he's saying he's 4.7
so in any one of these countries he's
he's packing a hog
to the local population exactly
unfortunately
it looks like he's in um central latin
and ecuador is the 6.93 capital of the
world so if he lives in ecuador he's
he's
he's gonna have a tough time obviously
so there's some geolocation stuff that
you can do
um this is country population
and there's a chart you can download
which i'm not going to get into is there
any more here
um international penis sizes compared
where does this take you
average size by country worldwide
again so they put ecuador cameroon
bolivia
up near the top and all the way down in
the bottom
is cambodia burma taiwan there's a
correlation apparently based on height
so
they're saying in some countries as a
percentage of your height
it can be as much as ten percent of your
height
your tool whereas in some of the
countries where you've got
less genetically gifts you're at six and
change
six percent of your height so and that
seems to be pretty consistent in the
smaller countries along with the larger
ones too so that's interesting
um data sources blah blah blah
okay let's let me see if there was
anything else there that i wanted to
throw up on the screen
origin data sources
manhood on a tree there's lots that you
could go googling on this one size okay
um so solutions to this sterling uh
adult film star
extraordinaire has a notch count of over
100 how many how many shots are
that much can't significantly higher
than that rich 500 thousand
what is it it's over 500 over over 500
so
you know coming from a guy that that
basically makes his living
uh going to pound town what is your
what is your recommendation for guys
dealing with a smaller johnson i mean
i want you to go first because you're
the expert here cool all right so
there's a couple of things here
uh actually i'll touch on three points
first one is
his mental frame of right of of
reference here he's like that i'm
this is not a problem i can solve
therefore i'm doomed forever
real i'm here to tell you right now this
is something you can actually change
it's a you can physically change the
length and the girth of your penis okay
so
relax you're not doomed if you don't
believe me
i have proof of it on the internet you
can go to sterlingtuber.com forward
slash proof
it's not safe for work so don't do it in
the library don't do it
again stealing cooper.com forward slash
proof forward slash proof okay so you
guys can go look at that later i'm not
going to put it up on the screen
i'm not put it up on the screen don't
link to it in the chat or anything
but that that's that's my proof pics of
my before and my afters so you guys can
actually see that this has been done
what is the what is the difference in
size that you're that
that you managed to grow your tool by so
it took me eight months
to grow i think it was 1.2 inches
in length over the course of eight
months okay in length
about a third of an inch in
circumference edition on the girth
okay and what was your starting point in
length uh about 5.9
so 5.9 you added about 1.2 inches yeah
okay that's that's that's pretty
significant exactly right i mean that's
like i got into adult entertainment
under like under average
for like you know a white caucasian dude
was that something that you were
like self-conscious about you're like i
really want to do adult films but i feel
like
you know i need a bigger tool for camera
yeah basically that was it like so i was
already good in bed
like i was necessarily think this is the
second thing i want to touch on with
this guy is like okay like
i'll answer a question first so i also i
knew i was already in bed i knew i could
you know
keep it going so to speak so i knew i
could do the job on camera
then i got my first gig or two and i was
like
i saw the photos and i was like ah damn
i'm not as long should be because it's a
bit hard to see this stuff on camera so
i'm like
that gave me like the impetus to like
put the effort in consistently every day
for eight months until i got to a point
where it was far more visually appealing
on camera
and it made my job a little easier it's
easy to like open up and stuff
so there was a lot of pressure like it
was good pressure it's what we call
eustress not de-stress but eustress
where it's like a positive stressful
uh influence on your life to thoughts
you do
you know the work that needs to be done
but so if you're a guy who has a small
appendage
first of all you can do something about
it second of all it takes time it takes
consistent effort but it is worth it
putting in the effort and the time
because
especially if you are currently
associating you know your sense of
confidence especially your sense of
confidence in the bedroom around like
the size of your appendage
when you increase it naturally that
confidence is going to skyrocket
because you're a totally different man
right
he also touched on things like premature
ejaculation so we can oh
once i get through these couple of
points i'm going to start giving this
guy some tips on
growing stuff and then on the premature
ejaculation stuff because it's also very
important
but the third thing i want to talk about
is
sex is a learnable skill right being
good in bed is a skill
it is something that requires experience
and know-how like
guys who have you know low notch counts
or you know
haven't had that much sex in their life
they don't have the prerequisite
experience
that someone like me has for example who
knows all the different buttons to push
on a woman who's had
lots of reference experience who's seen
patterns
again and again in terms of what turns
women on what doesn't turn women on
what compliant body language looks like
in the bedroom what non-compliant body
language looks like in the bedroom so i
know i can do certain things to a woman
if she does this
if she does acts if she doesn't why i
know what to do and where to do it
so that is also something that he can
learn which
puts him a far above the competition
because he's he's sort of
going in his mind he's like oh just
because i have a tiny dick
no one will ever find me compelling in
the bedroom and it's a complete lie
i can guarantee you out there somewhere
there is an mma fighter with a tiny
appendage
who is absolutely rocking his wife's
world every night in the bedroom because
he can go
like he can throw around and do a whole
bunch of really dominant things in the
bedroom to her
and when you're a guy who knows how to
do that it
separates you from the pack so he's
worrying about girls like
not wanting to have one night stand with
him and not being able to keep them in
rotation and he's worried about being
not being able to spin plates and being
taken advantage of
you know financially in long-term
relationships well
when you can do stuff that no other guy
can
then bam like spinning plates is easy
it's like a rotating door
they just come in and out it's not a
problem
you